ready up squadron came the command
through the team's headsets check your
gear and prep for departure Meyer
started methodically securing the
various pouches of her assault vest
tightening the straps over tactical Garb
and making sure she could quickly reach
her spare ammo just in case the mission
went sideways beside her the rest of the
Deltas on the team were doing the exact
same buckling into their seats or
checking their weapons were locked and
loaded sat on the opposite side of the
aircraft Cole had his helmet and mask
off loudly chewing gum with his mouth
open showing off the disgusting contents
when her eyes drifted over to him he
tried to give her a wink resulting in
Meyer's Walling her eyes you know you
should really close your mouth when you
do that Cole She said to which he
sneered back at her your face looks like
a clogged garbage disposal cut the
chatter gamma leader interrupted they
weren't present with the team instead
coordinating their movements from the
safety of an undisclosed location
through their headsets do I need to
remind you that this isn't a field trip
Delta unit sir no sir Myers replied
gritting her teeth good now then all you
listen up and listen good the voice
continued this operation has been
approved by the engineer himself so
let's keep it quick clean and quiet you
all know your target
scp-096 you are to enter site 19 capture
the creature and deliver it to our
client Valentin zukovic at the
Rendezvous location the use of deadly
force against Foundation Personnel is as
always authorized the team already knew
all of this they'd been over it in their
briefing before but the Insurgency
demanded total efficiency and zero
ambiguity about the Delta's objective
now each of you have been issued with a
pair of live feed goggles gamma leader
explained as they described them Myers
and the other members of the team all
produce their goggles as you know these
aren't just relaying your visuals to us
here your goggles have a camera lens at
the front and will transmit that fee
directly to your eyes given the nature
of the SCP we're going after the the
goggles have been programmed to detect
faces and pixelate them so you should
circumvent any problems created by the
creature's anomalous abilities Meyer
slipped her goggles over her eyes and
flipped the switch to activate them
immediately her vision was filled with a
feet of coal directly opposite of her
only now his entire face had been
obscured replaced with a digital jumble
of pixels it was exactly like the cop
shows she used to watch as a kid how
they would blur out a suspect's face to
hide their identity Delta Myers smirked
glad that she could no longer see Cole's
face while this is a definite
Improvement Cole She taunted now I don't
have to look at you chewing with your
mouth open another important reminder
gamma leader announced Mr zukovic is one
of the chaos insurgency's wealthiest
benefactors he's not just offered us
funding in exchange for undertaking this
Mission but if you pull this off he'll
grant us access to his fellow oligarchs
that means more people to offer
potential investment in the Insurgency
so remember Delta unit we have a lot
riding on this with that the aircraft
began to wear into Life Lifting upwards
off the ground the Insurgency had been
developing this new high-speed stealth
craft for a while a modified Troop
Carrier that was capable of both
vertical takeoff and Landing the
technicians had boasted it could reach
supersonic flight speeds in seconds
effectively launching chaos insurgents
at enemy locations where they could be
deployed complete their objective and
Escape in the craft all within a matter
of minutes oh and one more thing gamma
leader stated as the stealth craft climb
higher we have a contact with Insight 19
Junior researcher Bartram he's agreed to
let you in of course the last thing we
want is the foundation squeezing any
info out of him after you've departed
you know what to do safe travels Delta
unit a building mechanical sound of
Rapid acceleration filled the stealth
craft followed by a loud boom as the
engines kicked into gear inside Myers
and her fellow members of the chaos
Insurgency Delta's Griffith Slater and
Cole all grip their seats tightly as
they were rocked by the extreme force of
the Craft's speed it shot through the
sky hurtling towards the coordinates of
its Target reaching Mach 3 in a manner
of seconds outside the hall a sonic boom
rang out like a foreboding sound of an
ominous thundercrack invisible to radar
sonar and even protected against most
anomalous forms of detection the stealth
crafts zip through the air gradually
lowering its Breakneck speed as it came
within several miles of site 19.
continuing its approach the aircraft
slowed to a hovering stop above the
foundation facility unbuckling from
their seats each of the Deltas made
their way to the ramp opening up at the
rear of the craft and began to descend a
cable lower and lower toward the roof
Junior researcher Bartram had had been
pacing nervously back and forth near the
door that led from the roof to a
stairwell down into site 19. as he
waited for the insurgency's arrival he
couldn't stop himself from trembling
only to turn and feel his heart jump in
his chest at the side of the Delta unit
approaching him you Bartram Griffith
asked yeah yeah the researcher nodded
awkwardly we need your key card the
Delta said oh yeah yeah sure thing
Bartram rummaged through his pockets
producing his foundation issued ID and
handing it over it wasn't until the card
left his fingers that a thought struck
him the security system logs were
Personnel tapped in their card if used
mine to Spring 096 they'll think it was
me who did it that's the idea Slater
replied apathetically as Griffith raised
his weapon and fired a single Silent
Shot after dragging bartram's body away
the team used his card to unlock the
roof door and make their way down the
stairwell each one of them knew the way
they all had been to site 19 plenty of
times before back in the day you see of
all things with an equal and opposite
reaction in the universe the foundation
was born out of their own organization
the chaos Insurgency had begun its life
as part of the SCP Foundation and off
the books Black Ops unit created by the
mysterious elusive 05 Council as a front
to carry out some of the organization's
more nefarious activities but the
original Insurgency ultimately defected
breaking away from the foundation and
becoming a splinter group their sole
purpose was to eliminate their Rivals
the SCP Foundation and they'd utilize
any means even their own anomalies to
achieve that goal like many others
within the insurgency's ranks Myers
Griffith Slater and Cole had been
scouted while they were still part of
the foundation each of the Delta unit
had either formally been security
Personnel or a mobile task force
operator meaning they had the skills
that made them useful to the chaos
Insurgency on top of that they'd all
become disillusioned with the foundation
its constant secrecy and lies were
frustrating enough but their dangerous
and anomalous experiments all the deaths
they had caused directly or indirectly
had highlighted something far worse to
the Deltas the foundation placed more
importance on the containment in SCP
than protecting the world moving
silently through the halls of site 19
keeping their formation tight to cover
all angles in front and behind them
Slater gave a hand signal indicating
they were free to go weapons hot if they
encountered any foundation Personnel on
their way towards the target Meyer still
had her goggles active even though they
hadn't reached scp-096's cell yet even
though she despised the foundation and
what they had done not being able to see
the faces of passing researchers and
security Personnel made it a little
easier to pull the trigger the team
approached the airtight steel Cube that
housed their target all the Deltas knew
they needed to be quick while there were
no recording or surveillance devices
inside the creature's cell it wouldn't
take long for the foundation to spawn
the trail of bodies the team had left on
their way down Griffith gave a nod for
the others activate their goggles his
face already has scrambled pixelated
blur from Meyer's point of view then
with a wave of the stolen key card the
door to the cell opened as you may have
already gathered the goggles being worn
by the Deltas were actually based on a
pre-existing Foundation Technology the
infamous scramble goggles brought To Us
by the highly duplicitous Dr Dan however
as anyone familiar with 096's files now
those goggles were imperfect creations
and got a lot of MTF operatives killed
however scientists paid off by the Deep
Pockets of chaos Insurgency benefactors
had worked tirelessly on improving the
technology until they finally made for a
viable 096 protection device still even
with the goggles masking its haunting
wide jawed face and even after Cole had
gently thrown a hood over the shy guy's
face Myers couldn't bring herself to
look at it for too long it felt wrong
like it was forbidden despite knowing it
wouldn't harm her or the other Deltas
unless they look Direct directly at its
face
scp-096 was usually docile and calm when
unobserved and while it didn't seem to
be anywhere near as agitated as it got
whenever its face was seen the Towering
creature was notably confused as Slater
looped a leash around its neck and
started guiding it out of the cell with
an animal control pole suddenly the
alarm started blaring the foundation
knew they were there the shy guy still
didn't become enraged but began sobbing
slightly underneath the hood covering it
move move Myers shouted over the noise
as the Delta started doubling back the
way they had come traversing the
corridors back towards the stairwell any
of the pixel phase Foundation staff that
the Insurgent saw was quickly dispatched
bullets being spat out of the barrels of
their weapons as the Deltas reached the
roof the stealth craft was waiting for
them they quickly boarded with scp-096
in tow it sat at the far end of The
Craft hunched over itself rocking back
and forth slightly as The Troop Carrier
took off and shot towards its next
destination nice work Delta unit gamma
leader congratulated the team of their
headsets there's been a slight change of
plans Mr zukovich has requested us to
forego meeting at the agreed Rendezvous
he wants you to bring scp-096 to him
directly he's arriving at his compound
as we speak that was the part of the
whole operation that didn't sit right
with Myers at all they had just risked
their lives to secure the shy guy only
to hand him over to some wealthy
oligarch it didn't seem to make sense or
align with the insurgency's goals with
respect sir she spoke up what benefit is
this to us why turn over the anomaly to
zukovic what does he want with it well
Mr zukovich wants is none of our concern
Delta Myers the mission coordinator
retorted abruptly and as for the why
he's worth billions to us as a continued
Ally so I advise you to watch your tone
unless money Myers interrupted is that
seriously the only reason we're doing
this the chaos Insurgency aren't
supposed to be mercenaries we're meant
to be harming the foundation using
anomalies as tools to achieve that goal
there's a few long awkward seconds of
radio silence the other Deltas staring
uncertainly at Myers too cowardly to
speak up you're right gamma leader
replied ending the uncomfortable pause
their tone was in unnerving calm like
they were holding back from letting
loose and rage anomalies are useful
tools for us achieving what we need and
right now what the Insurgency needs is
to secure funding from Valentin zukovic
and his fellow wealthy compatriots so
for the last time deliver the package as
instructed or face the reprimand
arriving outside the compound walls with
barbed wire at the top towering over
their stealth craft the team marched
towards the front gate guiding scp-096
Along by its snack the creatures seem to
have calmed down barely making much in
the way of noise even with the hood
muffling it but that calm did little to
settle the tension Meyer still felt and
neither did the arrival of zukovich's
Aid coming out to lead the Deltas into
one of the many build buildings of the
wealthy oligarchs complex the doors to
the building opened and a cacophony of
noise came flooding out screeching
roaring howling so loud it was almost
deafening inside was like a zoo or a zoo
without enclosures all around exotic
animals were held in cramped cages empty
of anything saved for the Wildlife they
house the Reliance tigers bears oh yes
and many more besides these each one of
them was illegally imported or stolen
all now contributing to the Exotic
menagerie of one Valentine zukovic
welcome welcome my friends the
billionaire greeted them eagerly his
thick accented voice booming just
audible against the various animal
noises the operatives of the chaos
Insurgency for you sir V8 announced as
he gestured his hand towards the Delta
unit excellent excellent yes very good
get these hard-working people the case
zukovic replied with the swan of a sand
now let me see what you brought let me
look at my newest pet
wants it as a pet Myers heard coal
Mudder next to her zukovitz looked at
scp-096 with Wonder it was clear he had
never seen a creature like it but I'd no
doubt heard the stories of what it could
do reaching out of hand the wealthy
oligarch gently patted the creature's
hairless skin
he remarked in surprised when the shy
guy did little to react why is his bag
overhead a collective split seconds
Panic hit every one of the Deltas as
they watched zukovich's hand reaching up
to lift the Hood from scp-096's face
with Slater who reacted first grabbing
the billionaire by the wrist stopping
him before was too late sorry sir but I
don't think that's an advisable idea he
said releasing the man's hand zukovic
paused for a second an anger look on his
face suddenly he launched a fist at
Slater gripping him by his uniform then
struck again and again as their
benefactor kept punching him Slater
screamed in pain until he couldn't
anymore a sickening gurgle taking its
place when he was finally released he
fell to the floor still
is not advisable idea to touch me either
zukovitzka spitting on Slater's body we
meant no disrespect Mr zukovic Myers
spoke up it's just you shouldn't provoke
it anyone who looks at scp-096's face
dies the oligarch turned to face her his
anger suddenly replaced worryingly fast
with the look of curiosity really found
instant like heart attack he has been
making a death rattle then chuckling no
sir it finds them she replied reports
differ some indicate it kills anyone
that sees its face with its bare hands
the exact method is unclear because
there are never any bodies never leaves
any Trace if you see its face it'll
annihilate you completely that's why
they call it the shy guy
shy guy I like this zukovich left it is
harder to kill from inside the cage I
don't think it matters Myers thought
about shooting back with that but
instead kept it in at the moment
zukovich's Aid returned carrying a steel
case he reached around it and unclipped
the lid showing off rows of hundred
dollar bills bound together in Stacks
that they pay for fair day's work yes
zukovic announced as Cole went to
collect the case the AIDS snapped it
shut again that is just one more favor I
ask you to do for me the oligarch
announced I host party tonight big party
I want to show off my new what you call
it Shy Guy my friends are all very
wealthy could offer money to your
Insurgency with all due respect Myers
found herself echoing the phrase for a
second time that day without holding any
respect for either of the people it had
been directed at the chaos Insurgency is
not your private security Force Delta
Myers quiet gamma leader histor earpiece
zukovich's connections could lead to
potentially billions no trillions worth
of financial backing for the Insurgency
you will do as he asks or so help me I
will kill you myself a few hours after
begrudgingly agreeing Myers found
herself standing in the Menagerie room
itching in the suit zukoch's staff had
instructed her and the other Deltas to
wear all around her were more wealthy
corrupt figures with close ties and
similarly sized bank accounts to
zukovich the guests were Milling about
drinking flutes of expensive champagne
observing the captive animals up close
or taunting them in their cages in the
center of the room a new cage had been
placed with a shroud covering it and and
scp-096 inside friends zukovic Chanel
today is great day thanks to my friends
in the chaos Insurgency I am now the
proud owner of a creature like no other
he staggered towards the covered cage
gripping the Shroud covering it in his
free hand I present to you this shy guy
he pulled the cover away met with a few
scattered sounds of confusion and
surprise from his Rich guests only one
or two made frightening gasps at the
sight of what was within sure enough
they are sitting timidly in its cage was
scp-096 it was calm its face still
covered with its Hood it's just sitting
there one of the guests yelled hardly
very impressive what does it do Valentin
another one of his wealthy compatriots
asked well it ah mostly just sort of
sits there zukovic replied before
turning to look at the tall humanoid
creature suddenly without warning and by
a force of some intoxicated thought he
hurled this champagne bottle at the
creature do something have to pay my
guests he yelled the glass bottle hit
scp-096 and shattered instantly the
creature recoiled howling in pain met
with more taunting laughter from the
gathered guests watching it it started
shaking and sobbing heavily weeping
loudly which only elicited more laughs
from them all but Myers and the other
Deltas weren't laughing instead looking
in horror as scp-096 Drew itself up to
its full towering height and pulled off
its Hood it stared with sunken eyes at
the crowd their taunts petering off and
turning to silence for a moment
not so shy now yes zukovich laughed then
it screamed
scp-096 went into a fit full of rageful
Despair dashing through the bars of its
cage and immediately dispatching zukovic
the wealthy guests All Began screaming
in horror at what was happening as the
shy guy raced up to each of them one by
one killing them all in a chain reaction
for looking at its face Myers stashed
for the exit aware she didn't have her
goggles to block the side of the
creature's wide jawed screaming
expression maybe she could get far away
the stealth craft could take her
anywhere maybe fast enough to evade the
Insurgency and 096 she thought the shy
guy was too busy with the assembled
guests of the now to see sukovich and
that would mean she could slip away
unscathed it was only when she saw it
appear in front of her in the blink of
an eye screeching in despair as it
towered over Myers that she realized she
had thought wrong now go and check out
scp-096 a lesson in power and SC cp096
picture perfect for more stories of
everyone's favorite homicidal introvert